efectivamente biden ha tenido un
compromiso bien férreo desde que la
guerra comenzó no solamente con liderar
la alianza occidental sino con mantener
la alianza occidental en pie durante
todo el año pasado los miembros de la
otan tuvieron incentivos para
eventualmente retroceder respecto su
compromiso en Ucrania por los precios de
la energía por la inflación rampante por
el hecho que se requiere múltiples
compromisos económicos con Ucrania y yo
creo que lo que está haciendo biden es
en alguna medida recalcar el hecho que
la alianza se ha mantenido unida y va a
seguir unida pero también muy importante
levantar el espíritu y la moral de los
ucranianos que observan de que tiene un
presidente el presidente norteamericano
que los está respaldando eventualmente
hasta la victoria
como también hizo hincapié en la
respuesta unida no Estados Unidos Europa
la otan por supuesto como decíamos en
este sentido cree usted que Ucrania
logró algo que no habían logrado otros
conflictos Como por ejemplo lo que ha
sido el rol de Alemania tradicional
Sí bueno una de las cosas inauditas que
ha tenido este conflicto es que ha
logrado un cambio bien fundamental en
las posturas estratégicas de algunos
países usted menciona efectivamente
Alemania Pero uno puede incluir por
ejemplo también a Suiza o a los países
bálticos no hay que olvidar de que
Suecia ha hecho esfuerzos por ingresar a
la otan algo que parecía completamente
inaudito hace apenas un año atrás y creo
que este conflicto no solamente va a
observarse en este tipo de tendencias
sino que también va a significar eh un
cambio bien fundamental en la manera en
que el mundo mismo Está organizado no
solamente con relación al rol que tiene
las Naciones Unidas al mundo Alianza
occidental sino a la manera misma en que
conceptos como soberanía como democracia
y cómo lo Y cómo libertad que son
conceptos que enfatizó biden debieran
seguir siendo eh eh conceptos y nociones
que guían finalmente a las sociedades
libres del mundo ahora este
pronunciamiento de biden llega en una
jornada clave no solo se acerca el
aniversario de la guerra sino que previo
este discurso Vladimir Putin dijo que
iba a suspender su participación del
tratado del New Start estamos hablando
del tratado de reducción de armamento
nuclear que tiene con Estados Unidos el
único de este tipo que tiene con
Washington que representa esto que busca
Rusia con este anuncio Mire yo creo que
tiene tres dimensiones ese anuncio
número uno es intentar alarmar a la
opinión pública occidental a sabiendas
que sin su apoyo sin el apoyo a la
opinión pública occidental la guerra
terminaría siendo favorable para Rusia y
yo creo que enarbolar la alarma nuclear
una vez más puede conseguir ese objetivo
en segundo lugar yo creo que hay un
elemento diplomático económico en el
sentido de que Putin sabe de que esto
también puede ser una suerte de moneda
de cambio para minimizar por ejemplo
algún tipo de sanciones como son
mantener al gas natural lejos de la
aplicación de sanciones de orden
económica y En tercer lugar que también
Creo yo que es muy importante recalcarlo
tiene que ver con el intento de
desarticular la alianza que el mismo
biden ahora mismo está intentando
fortalecer no hay que olvidar de que
pudín siempre ha tenido ese objetivo
lograr a través de sus acciones o
declaraciones fisurar la alianza que ha
logrado hasta ahora mantenerse en pie y
yo creo que este anuncio Busca mantener
la triza dura que no haya conseguido
Posiblemente no se va a conseguir pero
con los otros dos objetivos Creo yo que
puede tener alguna oportunidad
excelencia agradeció muchísimo la visita
de Joe biden dijo que tiene una carga no
solo una carga simbólica también
muchísimo peso efectivo no sobre la
comunidad internacional usted hablemos
entonces del rol puntual de Estados
Unidos cómo queda posicionado Washington
a un año de la guerra
bueno naturalmente creo que queda con el
liderazgo indiscutible de dicho país con
relación a quienes liderar la coalición
la coalición desde el inicio de hecho
fue formada por el liderazgo del
presidente biden Estados Unidos por
lejos ha sido el país que mayor grado de
compromiso económico militar y político
ha tenido con relación a la guerra el
mismo biden en su discurso dijo de que
Rusia nunca obtendría la victoria yo
creo que eso también señaliza un aspecto
ligado a la moral de los ucranianos los
ucranianos deben tener o deben saber de
que tarde o temprano la guerra puede ser
ganado con ello con la ayuda occidental
y y estadounidense en particular Por
ende lo que ha hecho Estados Unidos Creo
yo que desde el punto de vista de su
liderazgo internacional logra recomponer
alguno de los problemas que el
expresidente norteamericano Donald Trump
generó a lo largo de su mandato